stay or go it was a fairly stark choice
for a caravan at thousands of Central
Americans a Mexico southern border buses
rolled up for those who'd had enough of
trying to go north we couldn't do it
there's nothing else we can do here the
only thing left is to go home they tried
to make it into the country on Monday
and this happened ever in yesenia two
months pregnant turned back when she
fell down you don't know what it is to
go on a caravan you don't know the risks
you're wrong like yesterday's case no
the truth is that I wouldn't because you
risk a lot and they threw stones at
migrants they weren't looking at who
they hurt but they can't go home they
say they've been squeezed out by
violence and poverty now things were
unraveling for them and others here
clothes food and patients all in short
supply on Tuesday many of the young men
gathered to plan another crossing they
didn't want us all Mexican authorities
to find out where there's a lot of
disillusionment here with Mexico
president Andras manuel lopez obrador
but talked about jobs and the
possibility of asylum but the reality
for many has instead been deportation
Yesenia lemmas is one of the lucky ones
after she and her two young children
suffered in the clashes yesterday they
will let go by migration agents and
spent hours walking the backroads in
Mexico avoiding other patrols we thought
we would have to spend the night in a
park but a lady came up to me and told
me to come home with her because of the
children now my goal is to get to the
petula and pass from state to state till
I make it to Tijuana she's still hiding
we had to do the interview with her in a
car now she has to find her way through
a South Mexico
loaded with checkpoints and the National
Guard looking for migrants her freedom
here could be short-lived John Holman al
Jazeera the Kuna man